hey vati when are you making that lady
maria prepare to cry episode
it's a great story and it'd be nice to
see it sometime this year
thanks man did you guys know that
halflight isn't wearing pants
it's true half light is supposed to be
wearing the loincloth
found in the earthen peak ruins which
gives him the wraps and the boots that
you see in his concept art
instead he's left with the default white
shorts which makes it literally
unplayable
but anyway strangely the game's code
does mark him as having a helmet
which doesn't show up because it doesn't
exist so
we think someone at fromsoftware
probably went to remove the mistaken
helmet entry but deleted his pants
instead the other secrets are better
like this one at some point it seems
that from software experimented with
an overhead blocking animation in dark
souls 3
which might have been good i guess for
surviving certain dragon bridge
encounters but
it probably wasn't deemed important
enough to have its own dedicated button
but what's more interesting is that it
seems they also experimented with
crouched stealthy movement in the game i
assume what this would have been
is you press l3 and you reduce your
aggro range like in sakura
and you know there are a few sections of
the game where i could kind of see this
working but
this idea needs to be really integrated
with the map design to be fully realized
without having low walls high grass or
tunnels to crawl through this idea
probably didn't exist for long
in development but after playing sakura
i feel really strongly that
stealth as well as jumping and swimming
should be a part of the future of this
series ages ago we speculated on how
secular might have been a sort of
testing ground for a lot of the concepts
that
i think could end up really diversifying
the gameplay
of eldon ring and all of their games
like dark souls in the future
speaking of the future of this series
i'd like to announce a new display
design
future souls is this envisioning of what
a sci-fi souls game might look like and
now it sits alongside the painted world
as two really sleek metal prints that
you can add to your collection
there's more on the way link in the
description and i'll talk more about it
at the end of the video
as aldrich consumed the god of the
darkmoon he dreamt of priscilla who was
hiding in a painted world
this dream allowed him to cast a phantom
version of
her life hunt scythe basically he dreamt
up a kind of miracle
but the scythe isn't the only weapon
that he dreamt up another is nito's
gravelord greatsword
which is attached to the end of the
staff that he attacks with and
gravelord greatsword was also a miracle
in the original dark souls
well turns out aldridge also has an
unused animation for thrusting his
weapon into the ground
which along with this visual effect
confirms that
aldrich was originally supposed to cast
a sort of
grave lord's sword dance during the boss
fight dark souls 3's bosses
saw a lot of changes during developments
not just to their move sets but to their
entire characters
for example the reference files call
osiros
dragon angel and he was originally meant
to occupy this
cut area of the game that was called
god's grave
it was a catacombs-like area that ended
up having a lot of its assets
repurposed for the ringed city in
osiris's place
stood the character that we know now as
gandhi
and you might remember that from these
leaked screenshots way back
but more than the boss fight just taking
place here
it's likely that gandhi was actually
designed to
be a former king of lothric just like
osiris was
his helmet does say that it was modeled
after a former king
so the fact that it's modeled after a
former king is either
a reference to his former role in game
or it could also just be a reference to
old king doran
from demon souls in early trailers for
the game
walney appears in the profaned capital
instead of the catacombs
again this makes a ton of environmental
sense since
walnier was a conqueror who pillaged
other lands
and yorm's boss room is piled full of
treasure the most powerful artifacts of
which
walnier is wearing and wielding himself
and this begs the question
if walner was here then where was jorm
supposed to be
well one unverified leak suggests that
john was supposed to be the game's
tutorial boss
which is possible because the untended
graves actually has a
giant coffin right at the tutorial boss
arena but if that were true then what
would the storm ruler have been used for
well in front of jorm is a message that
reads only a storm
can fell a great wood which is pretty
cryptic
on one hand it could be referencing a
greek proverb which goes
a reed before the wind lives on while
mighty oaks
do fall which seems to suggest that the
storm ruler
can fell tall enemies but it's also
possible that the storm ruler was
never meant for your and was instead
intended for the actual
great wood boss in the game either way
they probably should have used this
other message
that we found in the game files instead
in the next stage of development
the untended graves area had three
different world states and each one of
them had a different boss
so gandhi was supposed to occupy the
default tutorial area
and then there was a world state called
the eroded world state and
in here was supposed to be an enemy
called evil spirits
which had the reference name snake soul
and
while the character file for snake soul
was erased
the audio remains
and it matches the audio for the passive
man enemies in lothric
all of this calls to mind another early
leaked screenshot of dark souls 3 that
you might remember
where we can see an enormous black snake
looming over this desolate landscape
chances are this is a sort of drag heap
and
chances are this is the second boss of
the untended graves
the evil spirits or snakes or an abyssal
creature which appears to be leaking
from the giant dark sign
in the sky huge props to lance mcdonald
for teaching us about these world states
initially but the snake soul isn't the
only fascinating reference name in fact
there's this really long list of names
that served as placeholders
for early versions of npcs slave night
gale for example
once had the placeholder name yupa sama
which
is almost certainly a reference to the
lord yupa character from studio ghibli's
nausicaa of the valley of the wind
like gale yupa is an old cloaked
traveler who
spends his days searching tirelessly for
something
something that he thinks is immensely
important to the future of the world
even the painter has a kind of parallel
in nausica herself
making this movie which you should watch
by the way it's amazing
making it an undeniable inspiration for
the from software team the next point
pertains to philianore the hidden
daughter of gwyn that we found at the
end of the ringed city dlc
she has the reference name wife thus
it's very likely that instead of as a
daughter she was initially designed as
gwyn's wife
the identity of whom fans have been
speculating on since the original dark
souls
it would have been nice to finally have
revealed her identity but
in the end it's possible that from
software valued that fan speculation
over
putting a concrete definition of the
wife character into the game
and i have to admit it definitely is
sadder to think that gwyn would
sequester his youngest daughter away
in the ringed city until the end of time
the locust of the ring
city was called abaddon which is a
hebrew name used in the bible
for both a place of destruction and an
angel of the abyss
in the new testament i read that the
angel called abaddon is described as
the king of an army of locusts and i
don't think i have to tell you how good
a name that is for the locust preacher
in the dark souls design works miyazaki
details are part of the design process
that was behind
creating the four knights of gwyn so
ornstein artorias
kiaran and goff except he doesn't
mention them at all
instead he talks about execution of smo
and the channeler who the team was
encouraged to refer to as
four knight c and four knight d and this
was done in the hopes that
it would eventually inspire the creation
of knights a
and b in the end of course neither smo
or the channeler ended up as knights of
gwyn but smo's item descriptions do at
least reference that
he came close to being one if only he
didn't have that
gruesome habit of grinding the bones of
his victims into his food the reference
name for the evangelists in dark souls 3
is valegnano which is almost certainly a
reference to
alessandro vallignano a jesuit
missionary
whose job it was to convert locals in
east asia
to jesus's teachings and he went about
this in
a controversial way by encouraging his
missionaries to do things like
learn the language and the customs in
order to better
ingratiate the jesuits with the
population like valignano
it was the evangelist's job to travel to
foreign places
like the undead settlement and in this
case the undead were set on a path of
sacrifice
this road of sacrifices led to aldrich
the devourer
back when he was still settled in the
cathedral of the deep
for his reference name aldridge used to
be called salavan
and in turn salivane was originally
destined for greater things
the pontiff is a very significant
character
in dark souls 3's law not only is he the
master of sorceries
miracles fire and the deep but he also
managed to
usurp an age-old kingdom and he also
managed to feed a god
to a lord of cinder so he could supplant
the age of fire
therefore it really should come as no
surprise that he originally had a way
more important role in the game
he was the final boss and the reference
files call him black old king
and his arena was in the third version
of the untended graves
and if he was positioned where the soul
of cinder now stands he might have even
had
extra time to pull off this cut
animation
for buffing his two swords we're able to
view this
and all animations now in a program
called anime studio which
is something that's developed by someone
called meow meritus
and it displays really well all the
animations and
hitboxes in these games from has stated
multiple times just how much attention
they give to all of their animations
just in order to make them readable to
the player
and this program really well shows just
how
painstaking that process must be other
cut animations include
the backflip this is a bit of a callback
to the dark wood grain ring
of the original dark souls and funnily
enough it's actually performed by the
soul of cinder which
really helps us confirm that he's just a
larger version of us
and also an amalgamation of all of the
katana wielding dex flip builds that
linked the fire way back then
next let's talk covenants there are some
good ones in dark souls 3 but
a lot of them feel a little bit tacked
on and turns out
from had dozens of preset phantom
colours
at their disposal so that they could
quickly flip through and
suit whatever covenant color combination
they wanted
in addition dark souls 3 also has a cut
item called
the spirit amethyst which was likely
used to track
the corresponding colours of the spirits
in your world this would have been
pretty useful
but it is yet another advantage for the
host but you know the best thing that's
come out of all these different
spirit colours it's this jojo mod by
zuli that lets you capture enemy npcs
and attack with them
as your stance i'm gonna be playing that
one on stream soon
one enemy that almost made it into the
game as an enemy stand
basically is silver knight lido the
cut proof of a packed item claims that
it briefly summons him
and the animations that spawn here are
really varied they have different swing
speeds different amounts of swings
and delays etc but what we don't know
is exactly how he spawned was it from a
projectile
did he spawn behind your enemies did he
summon on your player character to
defend you all of these solutions are
kind of clunky
so i can kind of see why this item might
have been cut
and we started this video with an
incredible revelation you know so
let's end it with one as well have you
ever wondered what lies underneath
henry's headcloth
in this scene did the devs just place
the cloth over her head
or did they make the head invisible well
neither almost all of the details here
were originally discovered by zully the
witch
who is a must follow honestly she
regularly posts these
fascinating pieces of trivia like the
secrets in the video
and it was a lot of fun partnering up
with her today please check out her
youtube and her twitter in the
description
before i go i want to quickly talk about
the displate that i mentioned earlier
so this is future souls 1.0 and
it was created in collaboration with
francoise an incredible artist
we created this chaotic world that's
overrun by enemy ai and filled with
the husks of knights that have given up
at the safety of a checkpoint
they've sort of plugged into the
checkpoint and found it so
addictive and safe to sort of stay there
instead of facing the terrifying world
around them
but one night remains so like with all
my merch there are some really subtle
references to the soulsborne series
see if you can spot them if you end up
getting the print and
i continue to be super impressed by this
plate
again they're easy to hang without
damaging your walls the colour accuracy
and the metallic luster of the print is
really good
and getting this huge thing shipped to
your door is just
a really fun experience i personally
recommend getting a large
matte print but here are some of the
options that they offer
and you should get what best suits your
room thank you
as always for watching and i'll see you
next time
you